you know I find for myself sometimes I
stay with certain things because it
gives me an excuse
I'm gonna stay with this person that
cheated on me because as long as I can
always remind them they cheated on me
then that gives me a leg to stand on
that makes me a little better than them
or I'm gonna keep drinking or I'm going
to keep smoking cigarettes because as
long as I as long as that's my problem
and as long as I keep going in circles
of trying to quit smoking or not smoking
or whatever as long as I keep that
little problem going I'll never have to
deal with whatever my real problem is
as long as I keep this little
fish in the bowl I'll never even have to
really see what the shark is
so I just keep bout yeah I'm trying to
quit I quit for a few days I'm back I
quit I'm back
and sometimes it's like I don't know if
I even really want to quit
because if I quit that if I quit if I
quit smoking that I'm just gonna have to
phone then it's gonna be well whatever
what an exit I'm gonna to look at what's
really going on with me you know have to
[ __ ] be Neil Armstrong and myself man
not Lance Bruyneel ain't talking about
that [ __ ] nut boy with us with the
cycle I'm talking about that [ __ ]
Spacey daddy
but you said now about getting over a
man I think the truth is dude I think
you are over her
I think you just keep it around because
you don't want to keep you don't want to
move forward
and that's just a gas bro and that's
kind of messed up with me to say that
and I'm just guessing like by your tone
and stuff but also man I'm just saying
that because I can relate
you know I used to Pine over girls all
the time for this and that and and the
truth was I didn't really even probably
care about them anymore I was just
afraid to man up and [ __ ] live my
life I was too lazy or too stagnant or
to something to [ __ ] just say hey
that's that let's go you know created
this fake breeze that was just pushing
against me then but I was operating the
wind machine secretly on the side and I
don't have you know it's like aw man I
can barely make it through this through
this win but but as long as I every now
and then reach over and crank up the
[ __ ]
crank up the wind machine the fan then
the wind will just keep coming I'm
making my own damn [ __ ]
so anyway man I wish you look and really
what I really wish you man is the same
thing that I wish myself sometimes
confidence
confidence to say hey you know what
enough enough of that and let's get
going huh Wow you know what's crazy as
my sister can't even read but what does
it have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one